facilitator after you planned the garden
you plant the garden and then you're
caring for the garden to make sure the
garden is successful the last thing is
harvest and that's the most it's a
celebration
you're celebrating the fruits of labor
you're celebrating the harvest you're
excited but also the time of reflection
you could think back on what went wrong
in the planning process what went wrong
in the planting process and what we're
wrong in your approach of caring and you
can connect the growth of the garden
with the growth of the community not
saying that they're gonna grow
simultaneously together and that you
have a perfect garden the first time in
a perfect community the actually what
might happen is that if you're working
with a community that's not use the
gardening the garden might not be as
successful but you'll be able to see how
close the community is how the fabric of
the community has changed and that's an
important part of harvest because now we
can look back and think back oh so we
grew this vegetable we grew this
anything grow well here in our community
or didn't grow well in this soil
so let's rethink about something
different to grow it's also a good time
where a facilitator can bring in
different types of vegetables so again
you don't want to go in day one with
your own mindset of what vessels need to
be grown in the community you really
want to preserve communities and what
they want to grow but the second time
around in reflection you can bring up
ideas in conversation about new fruits
or vegetables for a community to try
they might want to or might not want to
also the community knows you more now
you came in day one it's a stranger
somebody keep me call you an impostor
but then as you care for the garden as
they see how serious you are about the
garden in harvest because you've stuck
out a whole season with them and they
see that you're committed to the work
then you can so have an additional
conversation about importance of types
of foods and things like that
you